die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend mit mir
im Studio für den Sport ist wieder
Christina hallo und guten Abend und wir
blicken jetzt gemeinsam auf unsere
Themen
wie umgehen mit China die
Bundesregierung will die große
Abhängigkeit von Deutschlands
wichtigstem Handelspartner verringern
immer mehr Hitzewellen die Wetter
extreme häufen sich denn zum Klimawandel
kommt jetzt noch das El Nino Phänomen
und Gewaltausbrüche in Freibädern
Bademeister klagen über aggressive junge
Männer und sagen das Problem wird größer
Wettbewerber systemischer Rivale so
beschreibt die Bundesregierung China in
ihrer heute präsentierten neuen China
Strategie 61 Seiten ballonsakt Berlin
will wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten
verringern beleuchtet kritisch Pekings
Macht streben und Menschenrecht
Situation aber dass wir ziemlich
deutlich ohne China geht es auch nicht
zu weit fortgeschritten die Geschäfte
mit Deutschlands größtem Handelspartner
Andreas
wenn es nach der Außenministerin
gegangen wäre wäre Deutschlands erste
china-strategie deutlich schneller
erschienen und deutlich härter
ausgefallen bärbock ist die Ministerin
die China am kritischsten sieht
repressiva nach innen offensiver nach
außen
china hat sich verändert und deswegen
muss ich auch unsere China-Politik
verändern während die chinesische
Führung Deutschland als nichts anderes
als einen Partner bezeichnet nennt die
china-strategie das aufstrebende
Riesenreich Partner Wettbewerber und
systemischer Rivale mit Sorge sieht die
Bundesregierung wie abhängig die
deutsche Industrie vom chinesischen
Markt aber auch von chinesischen
Importen ist
98% aller Seltenen Erden bezieht die EU
aus China 97% bestimmter Antibiotika und
83% des Elements Mangan mit vorerst nur
sanftem Druck und später vielleicht
stärkerem will die Regierung die
Wirtschaft zum Umsteuern bewegen wir
stellen Deutschland breiter auf
diversifizieren unsere Leverkusen und
die Versorgung mit wichtigen Rohstoffen
sie kennen dabei unsere Devise die
risking und nicht die kapling Risiken
abmindern aber nicht abkoppeln prompt
lässt China den deutschen Ansatz
kritisieren zwanghaftes die risking auf
der Grundlage von ideologischen
Vorurteilen und wettbewerbsangst ist nur
kontraproduktiv und verschärft die
Risiken künstlich
Deutschland sucht ein Auskommen mit
China ohne seine Werte und seinen
Wohlstand zu verlieren
wir sprechen mit Theo call in Berlin
Theo die China Strategie der
Bundesregierung ist ein sowohl als auch
wie viel Auswirkungen wird sie haben
können
nur das hängt nicht zuletzt von den
Investitionsentscheidungen der deutschen
Wirtschaft ab in jedem Fall dürfen es
aber Auswirkungen am Ende einer sehr
langen Bremsspur sein denn die
erheblichen deutschen Abhängigkeiten die
werden natürlich nur langsam zu
verkleinern sein das neue Zauberwort wir
haben es eben gehört dass die risking
also der Verringerung von Risiken des
beschreibt ja ein 10 Prozess es müssen
Lieferketten verändert und Rohstoffe
anderweitig bezogen werden die Regierung
macht der Wirtschaft kaum Vorschriften
aber sie sagt ihr seid selbst
verantwortlich wenn etwas passiert mit
euren Investitionen dann ruf bitte nicht
nach dem Staat die auswahlversicherung
werden künftig klar begrenzt klar und
kritisch ist übrigens auch die Wortwahl
schon in der Einleitung des
Strategiepapiers wird China für seine
Freiheitsbeschränkungen massiv
kritisiert es ist zwar nur retourik aber
auch das ist der Politik jedenfalls ein
bisschen danke theoroll nach Berlin ja
und wie wichtig eine durchdachte China
Strategie ist zeigt sich besonders beim
Thema Mikrochips und Halbleiter kaum ein
modernes Produkt kommt ohne sie aus und
fast nirgends sonst sind wir so abhängig
90% ihres Bedarfs muss die EU
importieren aber auch in Europa werden
Mikrochips hergestellt den größten
Produktionsstandort in Dresden haben
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck und
Außenministerin bärburg besucht Claudia
hier im sächsischen Sand soll es
entstehen das nächste Stück
Unabhängigkeit eine weitere Fabrik für
Mikrochips baut Infineon in Dresden
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck sieht einen
rasant wachsenden Bedarf deswegen ist
die Frage ob wir ein Teil der Produktion
und damit die Technik und das Wissen und
die Menschen die das die Technik und das
Wissen beherrschen hier in Deutschland
in Europa haben eine Frage der
wirtschaftspolitischen Souveränität das
Problem bislang kommen gerade mal 10%
der weltweiten Chip-Produktion aus der
EU das Ziel die Quote bis 2030 auf
immerhin 20 Prozent verdoppeln gerade
erst hat das Europaparlament dem
sogenannten chipseck zugestimmt der
ermöglicht gigantische Subventionen 10
Milliarden will die Bundesregierung für
eine neue intelfabrik in Magdeburg
zahlen eine Milliarde für Infineon in
Dresden experten zweifeln ich halte so
konzentrierte Subventionen für den
falschen Weg wir dürfen nicht vergessen
auch die chip-fabriken brauchen Produkte
aus dem Ausland und die können auch
ausfallen auch wenn es also
Produktionsstätten in Deutschland gibt
sie bleiben abhängig von
Rohstoffimporten was das Thema Rohstoffe
betrifft ist es ein sensibles Thema da
würde ich mir hier und ich glaube das
ist auch in der Arbeit und der
Bundesregierung eine Rohstoffstrategie
wünschen wir dürfen hier nicht blauäugig
sein
400 verschiedene halbleiterprodukte
werden hier in Dresden schon heute
produziert in gut drei Jahren soll das
neue Werk die Produktion erweitern und
die Abhängigkeit von Asien zumindest ein
wenig verringern
die neue China Strategie der
Bundesregierung ist auch Thema bei ZDF
heute live ab 19:30 Uhr in unserer App
und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
jetzt zum russischen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine der Westen plant ja moderne
F16 Kampfjets zu liefern um die Ukraine
zu unterstützen ein Zeitpunkt dafür gibt
es noch nicht Russlands Außenminister
laborov sieht darin eine nukleare
Bedrohung und das begründet er damit
dass die F16 atomare Waffen
transportieren können in der Nacht hat
Russland seine Drohnen Angriffe auf die
ukrainische Hauptstadt Kiew fortgesetzt
mehr dazu jetzt von Jürgen Kehl
Angriffe aus der Luft die dritte Nacht
in Folge Trümmer abgeschossener Drohnen
schlagen in Häuser ein auch die Abwehr
der Angriffe hat ihren Preis ein Mensch
starb es gab verletzte tausende kommen
mit dem Schrecken davon
erst wander Explosion oder Schüsse ich
habe die Kinder ins Badezimmer gebracht
noch eine Explosion da haben wir dann
gewartet das ist vorbei war
so zeigt das russische
Verteidigungsministerium die Angriffe
und preist die jeden Tag die eigenen
Erfolge alles laufe nach Plan doch
völlig außerplanmäßig meldet sich ein
General zu Wort Ivan Popoff
seine audiobootschaft verbreitet ein
Parlamentsabgeordneter Pop auf sagt er
sei entlassen worden als Kommandeur der
58 Armee in der Südukraine weil er
Klartext Rede der Truppe Fehler ist an
geeignete arteli und Aufklärung im Namen
der gefallenen Kameraden aber kein Recht
zu schweigen kein Wort dazu aus Moskau
am Tag nach dem NATO-Gipfel sucht man
die Nähe China's sofort hatte
Außenminister love auf einmal mehr die
geplante Lieferung von F16 Kampfjets an
die Ukraine kritisiert diese Jets
könnten auch Atomwaffen tragen sagt love
auf einer Online-Zeitung allein den Fakt
ist auftauchen solche Systeme bei den
ukrainischen Streitkräften werden wir
als atomare Bedrohung von Seiten des
Westens betrachten
nun russland hat diese Atom Drohung
immer wieder gemacht auch um die
Bevölkerungen in den westlichen Staaten
zu verunsichern und damit die
Unterstützung für die Regierung in
dieser Staaten die Ukraine militärisch
zu unterstützen schwächer werden zu
lassen das ist auch diesmal wieder der
Hauptgrund für diese Äußerung Russland
setzt auch für unsicherungen auf
Angriffe aus der Luft den Kia Firmen
froma wieder eine Nacht zu schlafen
es ist eine Zeit der extreme immer
stärker zeigen sich die Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels es kommt häufiger zu
enormen Hitzewellen dürren heftigen
Unwettern oder Überschwemmungen
Entwicklungen und Phänomene die nicht
nur bei uns zu beobachten sind sondern
weltweitinger Rabe und Marco
und wieder eine Hitzewelle in
Griechenland werden ab morgen 40 Grad
und mehr erwartet zum Schutz der
Menschen sollen Notfall
Sehenswürdigkeiten wie die Akropolis
geschlossen werden in Südeuropa aber
auch in den USA in Asien Lateinamerika
wird geschwitzt Meteorologen verbuchen
den bisher wärmsten juni weltweit und
Rekord Hitzetage im Juli ein Grund die
Erderwärmung aber sie ist es diesmal
nicht alleine insgesamt ist der globale
Temperaturanstieg natürlich da also du
weil es ist um 1,2 Grad schon gestiegen
dadurch werden auch die maximal
Temperaturen steigen jetzt kommt eben
noch dazu dass wir den Inu haben der
dafür bekannt ist dass er eben global
die Temperaturen erhöht das
Wetterphänomen Linie tritt eine zwei bis
sieben Jahre auf normalerweise Blasen im
Südpazifik Passatwinde das warme
Oberflächenwasser in Richtung Australien
in El Ninja Jahren schwächeln sie das
Wasser schwappt sozusagen zurück und
heizt sich vor Südamerika stark auf ein
Effekt der das Klima vor allem im Süden
beeinflusst dazu kommt auch der
Nordatlantik ist gerade fast ein Grad
wärmer als sonst und in der Antarktis
gibt es zurzeit viel weniger Eis als
sonst im Juni warum weiß noch niemand
genau ein seltener Mix aus Phänomenen
der Experten beunruhigt was wir zu
spüren bekommen ist ja die sind ja die
erhitzten Ozeane und Meere und es gibt
immer ein Zusammenhang zwischen Ozean
und Atmosphäre und wir werden in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten deutlich
mehr Extremwerte Ereignisse haben als
normalerweise denn diese Wärme muss
irgendwohin und die geht in die
Atmosphäre noch ist der Ninja dabei gar
nicht voll in die Gänge gekommen neue
Hitze Rekorde in diesem oder den
nächsten Jahren werden wohl nicht
ausbleiben
und die Folgen des Klimawandels aber
auch Kriege wie in der Ukraine
verschärfen den Hunger weltweit das geht
aus dem Jahresbericht der Welt
Hungerhilfe für 2022 hervor viele
Menschen warnt die Organisation können
sich Grundnahrungsmittel nicht mehr
leisten laut den Vereinten Nationen
leiden
735 Millionen Menschen an Hunger oder
sind unterernährt und es waren letztes
Jahr 122 Millionen Menschen mehr die
hungerten als noch vor Corona lüg
wahlport berichtet aus dem Norden von
Kenia
es ist heiß in Toskana im Norden Kenias
34 Grad im Durchschnitt und weit und
breit kaum noch Wasser die Bauern hier
spüren den Klimawandel hautnah
ausgetrocknete Böden Dürre Hunger
Existenznot Experten der Welthungerhilfe
versuchen zu helfen
das ist jetzt die fünfte Regenzeit seit
2020 die praktisch ausgeblieben ist den
Bauern stirbt das vie Weg es fehlt dann
Einkommen an Nahrung
die Folge Mangel und Unterernährung
allein in diesem Dorf zeigen 64 Kinder
schwere Mangelerscheinungen zusammen mit
anderen Organisationen stellt die
Welthungerhilfe den akut Betroffenen
familienfertignahrung zur Verfügung
das hält mein Kind am Leben für teure
Lebensmittel haben wir kein Geld
manchmal müssen wir zwei drei Tage ohne
Essen auskommen
was fehlt ist Wasser die Welthungerhilfe
und die Gesellschaft für internationale
Zusammenarbeit haben in Loki joggio
einen Brunnen Geburt versorgt werden
Mensch und Vieh und die lokale
Krankenstation
Wasser ist noch wichtiger als
Lebensmittel wir mussten vorher tagelang
nach Wasser suchen du kannst ohne Essen
lange aushalten ohne Wasser nicht
die Welthungerhilfe unterstützt die
Bauern hier auch beim Anbau von
hitzebeständiger Hirse für den
Eigenbedarf es sind kleine Schritte in
einem mühsamen Kampf gegen die
katastrophalen Folgen der Dürre
die Politik tue zu wenig für den
Klimaschutz so rechtfertigt die Gruppe
letzte Generation ihre drastischen
Proteste heute legte sie zeitweilig zwei
flughäfenlahm einer davon Hamburg am
ersten Ferientag dort gelangten mehrere
Aktivisten auf das Gelände und klebten
sich nahe den Start und Landebahnen Fest
auch in Düsseldorf blockierte die letzte
Generation das Rollfeld insgesamt muss
mehr als 50 Flüge annulliert werden aus
der Bundesregierung kam scharfe Kritik
an der Aktion
im April hatten wir hier über Lehrer aus
dem brandenburgischen Burg berichtet die
in einem Brandbrief wachsenden
Rechtsextremismus an ihrer Schule
öffentlich machten seitdem wurden und
werden die Pädagogen bedroht und
angefeindet überwiegend aus der rechten
Szene jetzt ermittelt der startschutz
und die Lehrer wollen die Schule
verlassen mehr zum Fall von Anna Bayer
Burg im Spreewald diese Botschaft hat
ein Ziel Lehrer einzuschüchtern die sich
gegen Rechtsextremismus an dieser Schule
engagieren die beiden Pädagogen hatten
vor zwei Monaten bekannt gemacht was
sich an ihrer Schule abspielt
Hakenkreuze an den Wänden rassistische
und homophobe Symbole im klassenchat
Schüler die ganz offen auf einem
Sportplatz in der Nähe mit Hitlergruß
posieren nun sagen die beiden Lehrer sie
fühlen sich in Burg nicht mehr sicher
sie lassen sich auf eigenen Wunsch
versetzen
Einkaufen in der Freistunde zum Beispiel
von zwei jungen
durchtrainierten
Erwachsenen ja schon massiv beleidigt in
der Öffentlichkeit du scheiß Zecke
verpiss dich aus Burg
ein Triumph für viele die so denken wie
der AFD Kreisvorsitzende er stört sich
schon lange am Engagement der Lehrer für
Demokratie diesen Post veröffentlichte
er auf Twitter bürgerliches Engagement
wirkt linksradikaler Denunziant verlässt
burgerschule in der Region Burg und
drumherum bis nach Cottbus haben wir
eine extrem gut vernetzte eine sehr sehr
aktive und wahnsinnig gewaltbereite
Rechtsextreme organisierte Szene und die
AFD ist inzwischen einfach der
parlamentarische Armen dieser
rechtsextrem mischszene nach
wochenlanger Zurückhaltung äußert sich
der brandenburgische Bildungsminister zu
den Rechtsextremen Vorfällen bin ein
bisschen erschrocken erinnert ein
bisschen an Zeiten die in Deutschland
eigentlich lange Vergangenheit sein
sollten ihre Entscheidung steht fest sie
wollen Burg verlassen
psychische Probleme sind mittlerweile
die häufigste Ursache wenn Kinder und
Jugendliche ins Krankenhaus kommen jeder
fünfte von ihnen wird aus diesem Grund
behandelt und die Zahlen steigen seit
Jahren
2021 wurden insgesamt 81
000 10 bis 17-Jährige wegen psychischer
Probleme in der Klinik behandelt das
teilte das Statistische Bundesamt heute
mit die meisten haben Depressionen am
zweithäufigsten sind psychische
Erkrankungen im Zusammenhang mit
Alkoholkonsum
Sommerferien plus Hitze gleich Freibad
aber nicht nur Badespaß gibt es dort
sondern in letzter Zeit immer häufiger
auch Auseinandersetzungen junge Besucher
randalieren legen sich mit dem Personal
an Bademeister beklagen Respektlosigkeit
und wachsende Aggression aus Berlin
Roman leskova
Berlins Sommerbad Neukölln geschlossen
seit Anfang der Woche offiziell aus
betrieblichen Gründen viel Personal sei
erkrankt am Wochenende gab es dort aber
auch wieder Rangeleien Bilder aus den
Vorjahren zeigen es ist kein neues
Phänomen immer wieder Schubsereien mit
Sicherheitskräften Schlägereien in
Freibädern der schwimmmeisterverband
warnt dennoch vor Verallgemeinerungen
Rand Erscheinung obwohl sie schon stark
genug sind aber die Bäder sind so sicher
unsere Kollegen haben alles gut im Griff
trotzdem sieht auch der Verband eine
Zunahme solcher Vorfälle nicht nur in
Berlin Mitarbeiter des sommerbads
Neukölln sprechen in einem Brandbrief
davon das täglich vorsätzlich die
Badeordnung missachtet werde verbale
Attacken spucken oder pöbeln üblich sein
in der Regel würden Jugendliche aus
arabischen Familien und Tschetschenen
auffällig werden heißt es für den
Psychologen Ahmad Mansour das Verhalten
Beleg für die weiter vorhandenen
Integrationsprobleme in bestimmten die
Gewalt hat viel mehr mit Patriarch
Infrastrukturen zu tun und mit eine neue
Dimension von Jugendkultur die toxischer
Männlichkeit und Gewalt verherrlicht und
sogar anerkannt und das muss in aller
Deutlichkeit benannt werden Berlin will
jetzt mit Maßnahmen reagieren mehr
Sicherheitspersonal strengere
Einlasskontrollen personalisierte
Tickets etwa die mit dem Ausweis
verglichen werden aber auch mehr
Präventionsarbeit soll es geben um die
Gewaltausbrüche in Freibädern künftig zu
verhindern
so wir machen jetzt mit dem sportlichen
weiter und der Tatsache dass alle
deutschen Tennisprofis bei wimbeln
ausgeschieden sind Christin genau wird
nichts mit einem Turnier Sieg als letzte
müssen nun auch Kevin Grawitz und Tim
Pütz ihre Sachen beim dritten
Grenzlandturnier des Jahres packen nach
gut einer Stunde und zwei Sätzen ist der
Traum von der ersten Finale eines
deutschen Doppels seit 1938 geplatzt
bis zum Schluss ein eingeschworenes Team
gejubelt haben am Ende aber die anderen
obwohl die spektakulärsten Schläge vor
vollbesetzen Regen den deutschen
gelingen Kevin Krawitz etwa
blitzreaktion mit gelungenem Hecht aber
der früher aufschlagverlust von Tim Pütz
ist selbst durch solche Aktionen nicht
gut zu machen zu stark in diesem
Halbfinale Marcel kanoyers und Horatio
sebios fast scheint es so als verneige
sich gerade jetzt hier vor der Leistung
der seit 9 Jahren zusammen spielen den
French Open Halbfinalisten gleich ihren
ersten Matchball verwerten sie bei
Aufschlag Krawitz zum 6:44 Uhr Erfolg
dennoch die Halbfinale Teilnahme in
Wimbledon der bislang größte gemeinsame
Erfolg des deutschen Davis Cup Doppels
[Applaus]
Bronze für prothesenläufer Felix streng
über 100 Meter bei den Leichtathletik
para Weltmeisterschaften in Paris wobei
sein Medaillen gewinnen auch eine
Geduldsprobe war
der Sieger stand schon vor dem Start im
Mittelpunkt denn der Italiener am humanu
fand offenbar nicht die richtigen
Handgriffe für seine Prothese bis er
schließlich von der Rennleitung verwarnt
werden musste auch zwei deutsche standen
aussichtsreich ihm 100m Finale der
Prothesen Sprinter
Titel Verteidiger Johannes florz auf
Bahn 3 und auf Bahn 5 paralympicsieger
Felix streng doch amo Manu und der Costa
ricana Sherman Gitti machten Gold und
Silber unter sich aus Felix streng
dahinter auf Platz 3
ich bin nicht ganz zufrieden aber
währenddessen kam der Sieger noch im
Zielraum seinen glücklichen Vater
Pflichten nach
[Musik]
nach mehr als 25 Stunden Anreise sind
die Deutschen
fußballnationalspielerinnen in ihrem
WM-Quartier in Australien gut gelandet
kaum angekommen gab es in der kleinen
Stadt wayong etwa 100 km nördlich von
Sydney eine kurze lockere
Trainingseinheit alles bei angenehmen 20
Grad australische Winter ja aber bei uns
wird es auf jeden Fall heißer danke
Christin mehr zum Wetter gleich von
Ostern terli das heute journal startet
wie gewohnt um 21 Uhr mit Maria Slomka
danke fürs zuschauen für Sie noch einen
entspannten Abend
[Musik]
schon guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja eine
regelrechte hitzeblase hat sich in der
Mittelmeerregion festgesetzt und
Temperaturen zwischen 30 und 45 Grad
sind bis in die kommende Woche drin 40
Grad und mehr durchaus in Spanien
Italien Griechenland und der Türkei und
sie sehen ja ein Teil der Hitze kommt
auch nach Deutschland aber nur für einen
Tag und das wird dann der Samstag sein
der Blick in die Nacht einzelne schau im
Norden aber oft trocken vor allem im
Süden Stern klar und die Temperaturen
zwischen 15 und 10 Grad und oft der oft
wiederholte Tipp lüften Sie die Wohnung
ordentlich durch damit der Tag
erträglicher wird ja und der wird im
Süden sonnig ansonsten nach Norden mehr
wollten in Schleswig-Holstein tröpfelt
es auch etwas aus der Wolken Decke und
das bei höchsten Temperaturen von 23
Grad dort und 31 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands und am Samstag kommt dann
die kaltfreund auf und kracht auf die
Hitze die zuvor hier herangesaugt wird
bis 37 Grad sind drin die Tage darauf
werden nicht mehr ganz so heiß werden
und die Gewitter auch nicht ganz so
heftig ein schöner Abend